take the field for the final time in
2021
mitch keller makes the start
and they pick off
that shock
newman on to keller
those numbers you see
35 homers and 96 rbis
mariners came back late last night this
ball driven toward left alford back
that'll do it
mitch keller
the bucks come to bat at the bottom of
the first
and he gets a second start back to back
against pittsburgh
and there's a start
for kevin newman
here is yoshi sugo
and pass bottle
oh newman
into third sutsugo into second
pirates in business
[Applause]
12 hits in 38 at bats as a pirate
dribbling up the third baseline
and
sun martin still able to get
chavis they're going to challenge
he's safe offered a ton of power
and this time he walks him
and it's one nothing pirates
ben in his career fine against lefties
273 overall
india feeds barrero
double play
the ground ball comes the pirates though
get a run now perez against lefties this
year an interesting slash line he's
hitting 130 about his overall batting
average
but he gets out base much better and he
plops one into ryan a base hit he's
gonna have two bases on this one
it's a double for perez here with one
out
big lead off third
and san martin works up for his third
strikeout the eruption of jonathan india
who has solidified not only second base
but also the lead off spot
look at this guy hit
and he tries for two throw to second
make it a double for india
it's against that average back up over
270. that's the kind of hustle that you
want to see out of your players
nick castellanos
sitting on 99.
castellanos to right
shushugo has to play it off the wall
india scores castellanos to second an
rbi double and 100 rbis on a stellar
season for nick castiano
wallops that one to right
castellanos leaps to make the catch at
the wall that was a nice play suzugo
maybe thought he got it but that ball
just hung up castiano's really knew the
park well enough to know when to jump
time to jump perfectly leaping into the
pads made the catch right before making
impact held on to it they really made
that difficult play look fairly easy
so man on for schrock one out of two
india off schrock slaps it to right
that's down
india had to hold in case he was caught
helmet off he flies to third shrock up
to second
and the reds have met at second and
third with one out
checking uh to see did he's out wow
about that the pirates appeal he didn't
touch the base he missed second base
he is out so india missed second base on
the appeal
safe
things down with shelter shelter
and he got hit
and he got run and he's ejected in the
final game of the season
derek shelton ejected in the fifth
inning by manny gonzalez in the final
game of the season uh
and you know i
i will take shelte's side on on most
occasions i'm not 100 sure what he's
arguing about here
because from what we saw there's
there was nothing that
said manning gonzales have it a little
bit
he's getting his money's worth
he's getting in there pretty good
one out aquino grounds a base hit right
between short third india will score on
to third bases schrock and the reds have
a 2-1 lead lefty banner 38 years young
bottle
rips it to right gone
36 homers for joey votto and 99 ribbies
a big inning for the reds they have a
5-1 lead
keno first pitch drove in a run
also later scored
[Applause]
drive to right center field
and that cannonball by aquino
[Applause]
off of banda
makes it six to one
people you know walking somebody with
the base is loaded and all that kind of
thing it usually is a
recipe for a big inning
one down as givens gets offered to
fly out to center field
camel
that double play ball ground out fly out
as uh sun martin went six gave up a run
on seven hits
damo will
end the season on a high note a base hit
manning with a gamble aboard and one out
the super two day yeah
flying ball to right center field aquino
back and clear the deck with a
cannonball coming
how about
that oh neil cruz
his first home run in the major leagues
in his second game
in his final at bat likely in the big
leagues this season
[Applause]
strikes out looking so brian reynolds
will pinch it
to left
schrock
and the 2021 season
comes to an end
for the 6-3
dred's victory
but o'neil cruz
hits the home run his first in the big
leagues part of that
ninth inning
nick castellanos
elected his 100th rbi
when the reds win it the pirates take
the final series of the year
but their record
61-101
the reds 83
and 79.